[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
a few cobwebs and some dust I am indeed
a student that I could very well be able
to help you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
Rebellion much better oh shut up wait
Akio
ah
he threw in my entire
foreign
thank you
Rebellion
foreign
[Music]
middle
rebellious
[Music]
that you get to go into it nothing to be
learned at Hogwarts that one cannot
learn out in the world
what am I missing
hello I don't believe we've met oh
but it's this painting I never noticed
it before if I know Hogwarts and I do an
empty frame doesn't appear for no reason
something more to this
have you gained any insights about the
painting since you've been studying it I
did discover that casting lumos has an
effect of some kind
but I'm not sure what to do next
if I have the time I may look could be
intriguing I've been racking my brains
long enough
I hope you'll have better luck than I
have
do come and find me if you stumble on
something that solves the mystery that
spot must be a clue
as you look around in case it's nearby
[Music]
lumos Professor watch out it's the troll
Slayer of hogsmeade
[Music]
this looks like the location from the
painting what could be so special about
it
lumos
let's get you back to your frame little
moth
huh I knew there was a connection I
should tell the Nora that I solved the
puzzle of that empty frame
[Music]
Lenora I solved the mystery of that
painting you did
how
I'm afraid I can't tell you Lenora
surely you jest
I am only joking
we found the location depicted in the
painting and then I cast lumos to guide
a moth back to the frame all very
logical I suppose
pity I was so close to solving it you
have a knack for solving riddles
Matty's good at that too
so is a meat although he does tend to
over explain
well I'm glad someone figured it out
The Moth
I should have seen that
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Sebastian took that dueling loss rather
gamely
foreign
thank you
[Music]
you can't imagine how inconvenient
travel was before I invented flu powder
[Music]
foreign
what are you up to now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
sometimes I'm not really sure Romans
teaching us a spell
[Music]
be the next generation or to become the
next year
heck it is intimidating but then she has
a serious subject to teach can't afford
to cover a cigar it might be too young
to be professor
knows her guilty from her girly
oh did you hear about the new spell
we're learning in charms I can't wait
you know it's gonna be a laugh with
Ronan
and have you seen how these professors
look at your clothes black looks at me
like I'm a pauper I swear the man thinks
I have fleas
I wish they'd let Ronan teach the entire
curriculum charms is the only class I
can stay awake for
foreign
what's up
[Music]
here I've come from the toilet bowl
where she said I could swim did you
practice your bowl as long as we're only
one time per week I can plunge the boy's
lavatory not for the mink these peers
will make me late he tried to stop me
did rancora's cup salt to trap me can
find me inside of a jar
but he failed us did his containment
charms so I took my revenge to wreak
havoc and harm it was granted my
privileges be handsome indeed or I'd
fire up so she agreed to draw up a
contract return
if you don't have one weekly switch
I'll get you for this
incident
[Music]
I'm glad you can make it lucan's just
over there
lumos
it's gonna help you
can I help you
Sebastian told me to see you about a
club if Sebastian vouches for you that's
all I need to know
sorts
nearly so you must have really impressed
Sebastian
I'm flattered to hear that
Sebastian's not a bad duelist either
imagine it's quite something to see the
two of you Jewel how does cross bonds
work exactly you show up I match you
with other Duelists and whoever is still
standing in the end wins it's our way of
determining the school's greatest
duelist once and for all and to liven
things up the winner is awarded a prize
interested
of course dueling's an entertaining
Pastime I agree but
first and crossed ones you could deal
with them if you like
the first time I'll pair you with
Sebastian next time you'll need to bring
a partner along or Jewel alone
so care to step into the ring
get me in the ring
let the fireworks begin
will make you regret signing up
[Music]
Springfield
come on
[Music]
there goes my wife
oh
nice work Sebastian wasn't wrong about
you there's strong competition ahead but
keep this up and you could be the next
school Champion brilliant Count Me In I
shall now it takes time to organize
these deals but check with me later I
may have something lined up for you
questions on your first crossed ones
Victory well thought
see you back here again
[Music]
thank you
glad you're back
hello Lucan may I use the training dummy
I'll fetch it and give you a list of
combinations to practice
ready to have a try now
[Music]
that would be wonderful be sure to cast
all of your spells before the dummy
lands if you need to stop practicing
before you finish all of them let me
know
[Music]
sit
excellent fall
foreign
[Music]
I'd say that's enough practice you
looked good out there thank you Lucan I
say better to discover one's weaknesses
during practice than during a duel
you'll be a fearsome Challenger now
hello Lucan is the next round of crossed
ones all said why yes it is I've got a
great match lined up ready for another
round
I'm ready let's do it brilliant are you
dealing with a partner
[Music]
yes Sebastian let's get to it
ready to get thrashed
apologies in advance
[Music]
back here
come on
foreign
[Music]
Bravo I gave it my all you did indeed
the other Duelists have already taken
notice of you but after that last round
they'll really have it in for you you'd
better keep practicing if you want a
chance at winning
or at least surviving the next round
I'll let you know when we're ready hope
to see you then
the next round is for all the gobstones
so to speak
[Music]
is hiring all right Natty told me what
the two of you did
High Wings fine I'm keeping an eye on
her she's safe Poppy I promise good
whatever the poachers are up to I want
hiring far from it you said you had news
about the poachers that some of it had
to do with me it did I overheard them
talking in the hog's head and did you
know that they have orders from Victor
Rookwood to capture you on site does
this have anything to do with Rookwood
and Harlow coming for you in the three
broomsticks after the troll attack it
does somewhat but at the moment I'm more
concerned about what else you heard the
poachers are up to fair enough
but I hope you'll let me know if I can
be of help especially after what you did
for high Wing does the name horntail
Hall mean anything to you I'm afraid not
why what is it the poacher's best kept
secret apparently
the name came up twice but they never
went into detail I also overheard one of
them bragging about all the gold they're
making at the expense of innocent
creatures undoubtedly the poachers spoke
of this area and I thought if we
searched around a bit it might give us
Clues as to what they're doing if you
ever meet my gran this trip never
happened
not to worry poppy if I ever meet your
Gran I shall not speak a word of this I
normally tell her everything she might
be my best friend after hiring but she
knows how I feel about the poachers I
think she worries I'll do something
ill-advised whatever gave her that idea
tread carefully
an entire Castle to Rome yet you choose
to wander here
please we don't want any trouble we're
simply passing through
do you take us for fools that we do not
notice more and more of your kind around
here in League with the poachers
we aren't involved with them if anything
we want to see them stopped
I hope for your sake that is true Our
Kind is swiftly losing patience with the
poachers and those they work with
he was certainly a charmer
they've gone worse centers aren't
exactly fans of wizard kind and the
poachers aren't helping matters but why
would he think that we had anything to
do with poachers
I did notice the poachers talking with a
few villagers in hogsmead I'm not sure
why
perhaps that's why the centaurs are
suspicious
foreign
than usual lately
I've noticed that too it's almost like
there's something in the water
[Music]
foreign
what is it
it's entirely sure but look around if
the poachers were here perhaps we can
find out why
[Music]
revelio
why wouldn't they take their cages with
them when they left
pelt
poor beasts
still smoking they can't have been gone
long
foreign
metal
seems out of place in a poacher camp
I should tell poppy about it
anything interesting
poachers were here all sorts of evidence
but I found something else it's Goblin
made I found Goblin armor let's keep
searching but carefully Merlin only
knows what's going on here
I don't have a good feeling about this
how do Goblin and poacher interests
align
look down there definitely poachers
no creatures though so what are they
doing out here let's take a closer look
they won't be happy to see us should we
use this illusionment or perhaps a less
discreet approach hard to say from up
here
let's get a better layover land
perhaps I'll Scout around felcroft for
something to poach
it's all about having a Keen Eye
my eyes is clean as a nipples on a pile
of gold or a nog tail to a sow huh I'm
not bragging that's just the truth phase
thank you
well we're talking about
ravennial
s
our centaurs quieter than you
foreign
you'd think they were guarding the
minister for magic himself what is going
on here only one way to find out
revelio
foreign
fighting ring
this is horntail Hall the name sense now
and the secrecy no wonder the poachers
were in hogsmeade so much likely taking
bets and spreading the words given how
crowded it is here how could they
possibly enjoy this the centers have
every right to be disgusted with wizard
kind there must be more dragons here the
poachers are far too greedy to run a
fighting ring with only two dragons
we should take advantage of most guys
being in the fight and look around
be discreet you especially can't afford
to be spotted
brilliant idea
then I walked into a sinking strong in a
bargain with them
I know yeah
[Applause]
ravalio
have you heard from your family is even
if your brothers come around to our way
of thinking when you join us ah they say
we go too far the violence isn't gonna
get us what we want Tiff I say if every
last wizard is run through with a blade
then violence is gonna get me precisely
what I want seconds me to work alongside
any of them don't know how ramrock
stomach's been near awkward fat Beast
not much longer now
soon our next will be out from under
Wizarding boots
wizard kind will pay for what they've
done
[Applause]
[Music]
value
[Applause]
foreign
what's going on down there
they must have only just captured her
she's putting up quite the fight
a fair one though not without chained up
like that let's even hard shall we
ravennial
s
look they've got a dragon egg Rebellion
from the looks of it
we can't leave it here not with the
plans they likely have for it
alohomora
foreign
I have the egg
ready
prize will only buy us a few seconds
let's make them count
problem
[Music]
too quiet
there you go
[Music]
that's scary
here today
all right
[Music]
vegetables
actually
kill me
before
Rebellion
this may have been a bad idea I suppose
we'll find out
[Music]
foreign
I don't think she knew they had her egg
she wouldn't have left without it what
now
she didn't exactly leave us a calling
card I I don't know nothing about this
day was expected not the goblins and
definitely not the fighting ring the
last thing I planned on was a dragon egg
and the poacher saw us which cannot be
good
since the dragon we freeze flew off does
that mean we get to keep the egg I'd
much rather we have it than the poachers
at least for now but I don't think we
should keep it indefinitely it'll be
hard hiding something like this from
Professor Weasley for long
we aren't helping ourselves standing
here let's get to safety we can sort
this out later you're right if there's
anything that poachers are good at it's
tracking their prey and right now we're
it
be careful won't you I shall see you
back at the castle